polio was making a comeback in New York
and other places but what kind of polio
strain are we dealing with today how did
it make it to the U.S and how can we
keep it from spreading continued
progress in the battle against polio is
signaled with the start of large-scale
tests of a new vaccine polio was a major
issue in the 1940s and 50s around that
time some people didn't go outside for
fear of catching it and if you did catch
it you could end up in one of these
but since 1979 it hasn't really been a
problem here until recently it has to do
with what's in these droppers which
contain the oral polio vaccine you see
there are two different kinds of polio
vaccines injected and oral the oral
hasn't been used in the U.S since 2000
both are very effective but the oral
vaccine is more affordable and easier to
administer and for those reasons it's
more commonly used in the developing
world but one of the risks with it is it
contains a weakened virus that can
mutate and regain the ability to infect
unvaccinated people that's what's
happening with a strain that's spreading
in New York called vdpv2
vaccine-terrived poliovirus 2.
this summer health officials identified
one symptomatic patient an unvaccinated
person from Rockland County in New York
now you might be thinking is the U.S
pretty good at vaccinating people
against polio and if the oral vaccine
isn't being used in the U.S how did the
mutant virus end up here 93 of babies in
the U.S born between 2017 and 2018 were
vaccinated against polio that's a pretty
solid vaccination rate but zoom into
areas in New York where polio has shown
up in Wastewater samples and you get a
very different picture in Rockland
County and Orange County it's around 60
percent so a lot of these places where
we're seeing polio here also have lower
than average vaccination
vtpv2 was also popped up in the last
year in countries like Yemen the
Democratic Republic of the Congo and
Nigeria these countries all have one
thing in common with the affected areas
of New York State low vaccination rates
it's not a perfect overlap but look at
this map the places with low vaccination
rates are where cases of paralytic polio
have also been reported one of the most
worrisome effects of the disease is
paralysis it can also cause breathing
problems and in the worst cases death we
know the person who was infected with
poliovirus in Rockland County New York
caught it in the U.S but we still don't
know where the virus came from
originally Health officials in the U.S
say there could be hundreds of Silent
cases lurking in the background about 70
percent of cases are asymptomatic so
that's just like a crazy high number
that's worrisome because people who are
asymptomatic can still spread the virus
and it also makes the disease really
hard to track in fact based on how many
mutations were found in the polio
patient sample scientists estimated that
this strain of bdpv2 had been
circulating globally for up to a year it
was also genetically related to strains
found in the UK and Israel
there isn't a cure for polio but three
doses of the polio shot were used in the
U.S are roughly 99 effective at
preventing paralysis most often
unvaccinated people get polio when they
touch their mouth after coming in
contact with often invisible particles
of an infected person's poop someone who
hasn't washed their hands after going to
the bathroom or someone sneezing or
coughing that's why the disease mostly
affects kids and why hygiene is so
important and if you're at all unsure of
whether you're vaccinated talk to your
doctor